foreign
[Music]
my family gets together once a year on
Thanksgiving I'm recently remarried and
my wife hasn't had much of a chance to
bond with my family due to covid and we
are all looking forward to getting
everyone together unfortunately my
elderly parents just told me that
they've also invited my ex-wife to
dinner which I'm adamantly against my ex
has known these people for 20 years and
that familiarity and level of comfort
will make it hard in my opinion for my
new wife to fit in she insists that I
could go without her but if she won't go
then I'm not going to go as my place is
by her side my family says that my wife
isn't that very nice your remaining
steadfastly loyal to your second wife
good
man of principle my family says that my
wife should just suck it up and deal and
that's um if we're not there we'll ruin
Thanksgiving for everybody so am I the
for thinking my ex should make
other plans and not attend my family's
dinner yeah you're the uh I
think on a number for a number of
reasons
first is getting divorced in the first
place and this is why you don't get
divorced divorced you just make
everything complicated for everybody you
make everything worse and everything
complicated for everybody for the rest
of your life including yourself that's
what happens you get divorced and your
family keep in mind
when you get married
it's it's not just you it's just the two
of you are not the only ones affected
you have families and your families are
now bonded as well through this Bond of
marriage your parents it sounds like
have accepted your first wife as their
daughter as a member of the family and
now they're supposed to renege on that
they're supposed to reverse course just
because you have
their bond doesn't mean anything anymore
just because you've decided to sever it
doesn't work that way it's like when you
you know when parents get remarried and
then demand that their kids accept the
new person as their you know Mom or Dad
maybe they will but that's not their
responsibility that's not their
obligation
they have a mom and dad
they only need one of each as far as
they're concerned
the fact that you couldn't work out your
marriage and you decided to break your
wedding vows that's not anybody else's
problem that's your problem you you
figure that out
[Music]
please
I have a 13 month old son who has my
last name because his dad wasn't
interested in fatherhood originally he
had a change of heart and tracked us
down two months ago to be frank I'm
still angry he tried to make me abort
our son and then washed his hands of me
when I wouldn't obey him so besides the
financial help I'm not grateful or happy
about a change of heart he asked me if I
would change our son's last name to his
it made me angry because I'm the one who
wanted him I carried him and raised him
alone until two months ago so I don't
think he deserves for our son to have
his last name however I know it would
benefit our son to have a bigger
connection to his father's family in the
long run so I told him I would change
his last name to his for x amount of
money he was visibly angry and made a
comment about how he wasn't as innocent
as he thought and he told me I was very
good at hiding my true colors while he
did agree to give me the money he's
being cold towards me now and I keep
thinking about what he said which is
making me feel like a real a-hole now
somehow again Reddit has said that this
woman is not the a-hole when she clearly
is now she might not be the a-hole
because there are two Hills the father's
a nail like showing back up didn't want
any one of the one of the child aborted
didn't want to be part of the child's
life and then you show up now you want
to be a part of the child's life and
that's good that's a good part you had a
change of heart but then like two months
later you're saying give the child my
name you have to earn that by being
present in the family now if this was a
normal situation healthy situation where
you're the father and you're there from
the get-go then uh then yes if the child
should have your your last name to begin
with but not in this case however this
woman you are still 100
000 the a-hole because you tried to sell
your son's naming rights what is he a
stadium why not go auction him off to a
bank let's call him a PNC or Wells Fargo
sella's forehead to uh Best Buy they
could slap a logo on it and you think
you're the good guy oh I know it'd be
really important for my son
no you're the a-hole he's the a-hole I'm
the a-hole where all the a-holes
on this episode of mibault
[Music]
owning a one-bedroom apartment recently
A co-worker let's call them Ali has been
coming to my supervisor to talk and
visit almost every shift
they've been talking about how Ali has
had a downturn in job performance and
might be laid off soon if things don't
improve Ali is nice and outgoing but not
reliable when it comes to office work
the past couple of days my supervisor
has been very interested in my living
situation always asking how the area is
how I decorate my space how my
relationship is with the property
manager they've even started making
comments about how lucky I am to live
alone and how important Community is
yesterday after hours
could we just get to the point here how
much we don't need we don't you don't
need to go back five years in the story
just get to the freaking Point
um okay for over a half an hour they
went on and on about how I could let her
live with me and how good it would be to
carpool split expenses and have company
at home I tried to keep the shock okay
so basically your supervisor is
pressuring you to have a co-worker move
in with you as a roommate you could have
just said that the whole rest of the
story is not necessary we don't need to
know what you have for breakfast that
morning am I the a-hole well no I mean
you're the a-hole for telling this a
long boring story but not in this
particular situation
I hear this story from people's jobs
sometimes and I'm just like what
first of all why would you tolerate this
to begin with your supervisor at your
job is trying to force you to to to
allow another person at your job to live
with you I don't know if this is
appropriate I'd better go ask Reddit
it's wildly inappropriate and it's
definitely illegal in like 50 000
different ways
so first thing I would do is go and get
that supervisor fired and then
absolutely you do not let this person
move in with you though this is coming
from someone who I would never let
anyone move in with me as a roommate I
think the whole concept of Roommates to
me just doesn't make any sense if you're
getting married and you're starting a
family right with someone that's one
thing that's not really a roommate you
get none of the benefit of starting a
family yet you get all of the annoyances
of having to live with other people in
your house part of the problem and I
don't know no offense to meant by this
but it seems to be mostly women who use
the mid a whole Forum on Reddit and this
is something women do and look ladies
you have to realize that you do this you
know if you have information that you
want to pass on to someone you you
always start way further back in the
timeline than you need to that's the
scourge of of of of existence for women
they're always complaining oh you know
the man they don't remember they don't
listen because you're giving us way too
much information okay and that's not how
our minds work we can't retain all that
we we're looking for the we're looking
for the point and that's where we home
in you know you've heard me talk about
how important it is to have a VPN to
protect your online privacy but choosing
a VPN you trust is equally as important
I like to do my research on my sponsors
and I only recommend Brands to my
listeners that I believe in to actually
stop people from monitoring your online
activity you need to do what I do and
use expressvpn think about all the times
you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop Hotel
even a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network that's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
especiallypn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
private expressvpn works on all your
devices it's super easy to use the app
has one button you tap it to connect and
your browsing activity is secure stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself and
expressvpn.com
walshyt use my Link at expressvpn.com
Walsh YT to get three extra months free
that's exp
rssvpn.com Walsh YT
[Music]
let's see